a lot of artists obviously you've done
kind of your version of this but like a
lot of artists these days there's
serious seven figure bags out there to
do a podcast yeah I feel like if you did
like oh the Ray J podcast will go crazy
I I mean millions of dollars are just
ready for you for the taking I would
love that like I I got so much [__] to
get off my chest and so many topics to
touch on to go viral on like I'm so
chill now because I know if I just turn
up just a little bit it's gonna go viral
so I'm trying to calm my virulicity down
let me tell you let me tell you this let
me get let me give him another like
Vince Staples Moment Like bro he'll just
casually tell me like yeah I'm like I'll
talk about Tupac Stories the old death
for all this but yeah Park used to swim
we used to cruise up and down Sunset
like a man how old were you when Tupac
was picking you up was he babysitting no
no Snoop was picking me no snoopers the
pack was always at um Pac was always at
Can-Am and I'm saying you remember
Can-Am I I was no of course not oh it
was I grew up in Phoenix
um yeah for sure park for sure man I
mean [__] that's [__] what's it like
riding like getting picked up by Snoop
Dogg as a child I mean we're talking 90s
Snoop yeah this is it this is this this
shit's different well you know that's my
cousin you know what I'm saying but like
what's that like like Peak Snoop Dogg
biggest rapper in the world scooping you
up you're riding around with them well I
was I I had to be low-key because Brandy
was was super popular moesha's on TV
she's one of the biggest singers in the
world you're her little brother and his
clean cut on our side then our cousin
Super League so I had to like hide you
know what I'm saying but I was having
fun I was bad but um
[__] by the grace of God like we made it
through all of that because you know La
is a dangerous place and um you know a
lot of people didn't make it through so
I'm I'm blessed and I'm just happy to be
here and I love everybody if I ever said
something crazy or we ever had an
altercation I love you I'm sorry I like
going to the grocery store by myself and
you know what I'm saying having a good
time with the family so if there's
anything out there that was irregular in
the past it's my fault even if it wasn't
I love you and peace be with you
wow turn to No Leaf man yeah man I like
that I feel like the new Leaf's been
turned for you for a while though yeah
yeah I mean the shows that we do don't
reflect it a lot uh just so just our day
to day but I think I'm gonna just go
ahead and just like flip it around and
just release
focus on like what the real narrative is
um and just take a back seat to like
doing the shows and just start producing
the shows you know what I'm saying just
not being on camera yeah I mean yeah but
you're so good on camera
like a yoga Wellness Retreat too I mean
it's like
growth I'd go to yoga three days a week
what you'll be doing in there how yoga
downward dog hot yoga pause pause
I mean that's what I should be doing
what's a downward dog pause I mean
that's what yoga poses the downward dog
is way up there
no but that's a high level pause that's
positive about a week but it's bro no
it's not because have you done the
downward dog their room was awesome is
really good for the Mind Body and Soul
have you ever done Ayahuasca I've never
done I'm not a real druggie kind of guy
well first of all yeah it's not drugs
you did it no I've only done uh lots of
mushrooms I'm not about to do the toe
Venom and then you got to put your whole
self back together have you smoked the
toad Venom yeah I had a shrimp summer
while I was loving the chocolate straws
no DMT though no DM I don't do drugs bro
my boy Aki David always tried to get me
to come to Malibu and DMT with them but
you should have did it nah I came Mike
Tyson does it all the time like I don't
want to do DMT and then when I come when
I when I'm reborn I'm like a Buddhist
and I want to do the music and Tech no
more I've had friends in Oakland who've
just tried the wrong drug and their
brains get rewired well that's fentanyl
no before fentanyl like their brains
just get rewired and they never the same
so you got to be careful with stuff I
was just in Portland this past weekend
everyone's just doing drugs on the
street yeah no Portland you know what
else is like it's it's legal though in
Portland all the drugs are legal so you
found Vancouver you could shoot up
heroin in front of the cops and they're
just like you all right you need
anything see how San Francisco's pretty
bad San Francisco's [__] up you know
it's pretty bad but it's like just went
to San Francisco and we was trying to
find the Golden Gate Bridge we like I
think it's way on the other side I think
we was adjacent to it you hear how I
know how you see these words I'm using
hey Jason
like some of the most billionaires some
of the like highest rent and then some
of them with extreme wealth is Extreme
poverty yeah of course crazy man it's
got them City you feel me but it's
definitely Gotham City I love the bay
hey what up Bae the princess from the
bay
they love raining about totally fell
yeah I'm Filipino now because princess
Filipino my kids Filipino Ray J Phillips
have you ever ate the balut the bullet
yeah the the Filipino like half eaten
bird I eat chicken adobo all the time I
don't do it I like the lumpia guys has
your lady ever done it of course yeah
has she done it in front of you yeah
would you go shout out my brother E40 he
just opened he's opening up Olympia yeah
he's got a lumpia company yeah let's
open up an Olympia what is that lumpy is
like uh the Filipino kind of like egg
roll kind of small oh
hi
you can hear the little bones crack I
could say this entrepreneurial wash E-40
and Ray got a lot of parallels yeah you
guys really do honestly doing different
like E4 he's got like 38 businesses
we'll tell you something E40 is a great
guy man I love him he's a great guy it's
California West Coast yo you gotta
launch a podcast and your first episode
should be the sky store to E40 for
different reasons I mean the thing about
it is like I want to launch a podcast
like I don't know I do like my own
podcast at home for fun and look at it
and laugh with guests bro you're [__]
it's it's a million dollars easy through
all my podcasts I did at home just for
fun but you gotta really like take it
serious so I've been taking it seriously
I got like 50 episodes that it's just
throwaways I'm never gonna use them but
that's how much I'll be having fun no
crib shut up
but you got to do one like Drop it once
a week four times a week no no no you
gotta drop it once a week if they if I
listen you're too busy if I get the
proper bag me and my team will produce
25 shows a week that's too much no it's
not no Ray let me tell you what it is
what you do
how many well you already got a YouTube
channel
I never promoted it now it's Ray J TV I
got like 8 000 subscribers no but where
the [__] are your songs at
um
which one where they at
Rachel Vivo okay Vivo okay well listen
Ray Ray J Vivo I thought that was on
Spotify
I'm telling you if you just lock first
of all you did we get my code yet you
don't need The Upfront bag
do it for six months on your own and
then you'll be able to get a stoop you
just gotta tell me the number so we
don't know how to scale it on our own
and then build it you know what I'm
saying you have the YouTube Revenue
you'll be able to get your own
sponsorship money but [__] all that once
oh [__] why is he here yo Ray okay let
me ask you a question so Kev Jesus
[__] okay for on top you like the
song what's our next move what's our
next play for what for your guys's music
yeah foreign
I think you guys are already doing the
right [__] to drum up Buzz I think like
I saw like you guys were on TMZ I think
you know the tick tock shit's always
important shout out to TMZ I would say
whatever you guys do don't spend money
in the wrong places because I see
artists nowadays
what are
the wrong places you know I see [__]
rappers these days they'll be like yo
um I hired this person and they got me
on complex
we'll work on that but I'm saying like
for any up and coming artists if someone
[__] tries to sell you on getting you
on like lyrical lemonade.com or
complex.com
keep your [__] money because you
might as well just set it on fire in the
middle what about what about what about
what about what about walking what about
what about Walmart walmart.com I didn't
ask you why don't anybody can get on
Walmart that's what I'm saying I just
want you I just want you to teach them
because if they say well forget this
time I'm gonna put you on Walmart
that should be I mean listen I mean I
want to know some of y'all do you think
you're gonna get the ROI on the on the
water on the balloon
it could be organically it'll go viral
for a day but will that translate to
streams so let's talk let's talk about
conversion marketing after this and talk
about what we got at the end of the day
anything you guys do should try to be
how do we convert that into listenership
before we leave I don't need a bag but I
want you to have one shut the [__] up I
want you to have fat [__] who's got this
guy's got [__] Super Trooper shades
on
anyway Big B
um so so look he's my best friend in my
manager in it you didn't really give me
you told me the donuts you didn't he's
58 years old so so Bobby Bobby brackens
is really wants the the good advice from
you on what to do I think I think
number one is consistency especially for
you let's say take Reggie out of the
picture you're very inconsistent with
your music
super inconsistent Kev is right because
I feel like maybe 2017 I remember you
had the single with G or was that 2018.
one was Zendaya they went crazy but the
thing is is like you'll put some [__]
out and then you'll go away so it's like
bro you can't expect yeah you can't
expect
people to go ahead and get it give it to
them like stay with you because the the
attention span of all these fans is this
big so they're gonna forget about you
there you go so if if I want the good
advice I don't want to do nothing no I'm
giving you I'm giving you good advice
consistency because you can look at some
of your your peers just from your area
right who's been super consistent Larry
June uh burner mozzie from Sacramento
like mozzie just non-stop it's like he's
just feeding his fans so my thing with
you is like Bobby you are a talented
artist you do have a fan base you have
listenership on Spotify you feed them
consistently and don't and if something
doesn't work one not every song needs a
budget it not every song needs a radio
campaign there we go now you're giving
there are context records that you could
drop just to feed your fan base and
guess what if you drop and you're like
oh [__] this [__] organically is doing
its own thing the fans will tell you we
need to put a little bit of gasoline on
this and that's what the body will work
so they'll be like yo we love this on
top is big but this [__] we going crazy
over we scale this one they're on top
yeah and then the other thing is it's
like like look at this cake I'll tell
you something real quick like my thing
right knows too like just being around
me I never I never cared about being the
most famous person I just love making
music if I gotta if I gotta put it no
you're obviously a successful artist but
you can't love it and keep it to
yourself
exactly if I gotta if I'm giving it to
other people I'm fine with that but it's
like if I'm sitting on a million records
on my email that I know somebody needs
to cut
a lot of artists
a lot of artists will out think
themselves
are we getting naked boys
oh he's getting naked yeah anymore of
course yeah you know do you still get a
bag off of that like any sort of
residual check man I've really just been
focused on you know the tech and you
know but does a check come in still well
what happened was you know after I
started going to the gym I just started
to lose focus on like everything on that
kind of side of things in life so I've
been just kind of forgetting about
yeah
my my uh my son's best friend's cousin's
mom is married to the guy who owns Vivid
so yeah yeah so and like he's like best
friends with Chris Paul's son and [__]
so my son was a great guy my son was
just over at his house for a birthday
party and he was like I was at the house
the porn built I was like yes you were
yeah Steve's a good guy so you have you
still have you have a relationship with
Steve hi Steve not really I mean I love
Steve but I just did some good business
and we know when you become a dad and
just they've been just changing around
and grow you you really reach out to
anybody you just so like locked down
I have two kids is that a Sublime tattoo
yeah [__] that's like my second favorite
band ever I didn't know you was tatted
up like that yeah yo what age were you
when you got these tattoos some of these
look like they are jailhouse uh you know
of different ages 18 19 21. summer jail
house summer very professional this is
like hipster no there's some that look
really good and then like the sublime
tattoo I'm a Sublime fan I know what it
is but like yeah I got that a minute ago
do I got another t-shirt
do you want a shirt I mean I'm wet
pause pause I got a son of these lights
but it's all gravy oh yeah you're
sitting right under the lights yeah the
problem is is that that's the only thing
that Cas Amigos need to take away from
their drink is that it creates sweat
and they if they can take the sweat the
sweat ingredient out where you can drink
and don't sweat then casamigos will be
popping but I swear I don't sweat until
I drink you make that make that girl
where you don't perspire I know
desperation to keep it it is also kind
of hot in here I'm just not in the
liquor we just moved into this space and
we're still trying to get the AC
together guys yeah no doubt it's just
I'm happy bro holler at 40 bro I even
know some vendors up in Napa Valley no
no I don't want to get in the liquor
business